- [Instructor] A cart of
mass, m, moving rightward
at speed two v,
hits a slower moving cart
of mass, m,
moving rightward at speed v.
When the carts collide,
they hook together.
There is friction between
the track and carts
and between the moving parts of the carts.
Which of the following best
represents the momentum
of the left-side cart
as a function of time
before and after the collision?
So before we even look at the choices,
let's see if we can
sketch it out ourselves.
So pause this video
and see if you can make a sketch
of what the momentum of the left-side cart
would look like as a function of time.
And actually try to do it
for the right-side cart
while you're at it.
All right now let's do this together.
So just to make sure we
understand what's going on,
this cart is moving,
they have the same mass.
This left cart is moving to the right
with a velocity of two v,
the cart on the right has the same mass
and it's moving to the right
with half the velocity.
And since momentum is mass times velocity,
this will also have half the momentum.
So one way to think about it is,
if on our vertical axis,
let me draw a straighter line.
If on our vertical axis,
we have momentum.
Momentum.
And on our horizontal axis,
we have time.
So this is
time,
right over there.
So this left cart will
start with some momentum
but since there's friction in the system,
especially in the mechanics of this cart,
you're going to see it slow down.
The force of friction
is going against the direction of motion
so it's going to decelerate it.
And then its going to hit
the other slower moving cart
and that other slower,
and one way to think about it is
some of the momentum will get transferred
to the slower moving cart
because then they're going
to be moving together
at the same velocity.
And so, you could imagine,
and then at that slower velocity
will continue to decelerate
because of the friction.
And so the graph of momentum
over time of the left cart
might look something like that.
Now, just for kicks,
if you wanna think about,
what about the right cart?
Well, the right cart has the same mass
but half the velocity.
So it's going to have
half the initial momentum.
And so it would also degrade,
it would look something like this.
But then right at the collision,
the right cart would gain momentum.
And then they should
go together like that.
So these are the lines
for each individual one.
And if you wanted the combined system,
well, then you would add these momentums
and you would have something
that just would be a line
that degrades.
But anyway, they asked
us about the left cart.
And so we said hey, something
something that looks like
this should work out.
So let's look at the choices.
So,
this first choice has
two problems with it.
First, it shows a world in
which you have no friction.
It's just, the momentum stays constant,
and so that means its
velocity to the right
is staying constant.
And then when its trying
to show the collision,
it makes the momentum negative.
And this would imply that all of a sudden,
that cart would be moving to the left.
Where the convention that we typically use
is right is positive and left is negative.
And so we can rule this one out.
This second one looks a little bit better.
But once again, it's assuming
a world without friction.
Where the velocity stays constant
and so the momentum stays constant.
And still you have the collision,
and then you still have
it after the collision
the momentum stays constant.
So we can rule that out.
If they said it was frictionless,
this is what we would have picked.
Choice D, it's looking
good in the beginning
but then it shows that
the momentum goes to zero.
Implying that the left cart
just comes to a standstill.
And once again, we would not expect that.
And so we would rule that out.
And so this is very close
to what we drew, choice B.